- Ella, congratulations on
the success of Dickinson.
You have a great American
accent in the show.
Was that a lot of practice?
Was that hard?
- So one of my favorite
things to do as a child
was to, well, first off,
I was just obsessed with Legally Blonde
and really American culture as a whole.
And my favorite thing to do for my friends
or the thing I did to make them laugh
was to pretend I was an
American woman at a nail salon.
So I'd be like, oh my
God, I just broke a nail.
Do you, how do I fix it?
Do I get like, do I get the blush?
Do I get the rouge?
Like, that was what I did for my friends.
- I, first of all, I love.
- Excellent, excellent.
- I know, but I love that she said,
well, I was obsessed
with American culture.
Like I loved Legally Blonde.
And I'm like, just so you know,
there's more to us than Legally Blonde.
You've got to dive deeper,
Ella, you've got to dive deeper.
- Yeah, go deep.
- In nail salons or becoming lawyers.
That was all you Americans did in my head.
(Kelly laughing)
- That's my favorite!